sur ce site de nevers près de 410
salariés fabrique des verrous et antivol
automobile des systèmes mécaniques de
plus en plus délaissée par les
constructeurs
alors d'ici 2022 ue chine devrait
supprimer environ 215 emplois c'est
énorme ce la moitié des personnels ces
landes
ces catastrophes on se doutait qu'il y
allait avoir quelque chose mais c'est
vrai que quand ils nous ont annoncé plus
de 200 suppressions d'emplois ben ça
fait mal quoi on pensait pas autant le
plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi prévoit
des départs par vagues
alors les salariés ont du mal à se
projeter on peut vivre que la boule au
ventre on va attendre deux ans de savoir
si on est dans l'eau si quand on va
partir heures c'est ça le plus long je
pense c'est d'attendre
ici beaucoup ont fait toute leur
carrière dans l'entreprise et craignent
de se retrouver sur un marché du travail
sinistrés moi ça fait un peu plus de 26
ans je suis là donc assez vrai que c'est
pas qu'on ait vieilli mais bon c'est une
usine des lycées en taille a pas de
jeunes là on connaît la plupart des
postes qui sont supprimés ou en
l'occurrence j'en fais partie une
reconversion certainement prévoit là
dans un bassin comme comme lanières ou
le fan en pole pas terrible ça va être
compliqué peuvent les représentants du
personnel redoute même que la
réorganisation n'assure pas la pérennité
du site
il ya deux raisons soit une raison on
veut faire la mariée plus belle pour
pouvoir nous vendre plus tard ou la
deuxième raison qui peut être réelle
mais il faut nous amener des éléments
qui nous permettra de dire notre site a
de l'avenir
la direction du groupe n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer à ce stade des négociations
elle nous a fait savoir par une porte
parole que la priorité était de
maintenir le site de nevers maltais le
virage stratégique
les discussions vont maintenant se
poursuivre jusqu'au mois de mars pour
rechercher de nouveaux marchés et
définir les contours définitifs du plan
social